hard to disagree  is doing the right thing by not even  allowing any of that yeah  somewhere around here it's  yeah  that was a kind of a funny Exchange in  in chat which shows that some people  really have not seen me talk about Chess  very much because  i i in that story I think against  gelfand I mentioned my strong desire to  resign after I blundered that thing in  the opening  and somebody said uh Peter's laugh where  the resignation's heart emoji heart  emoji and somebody said Peter Banu  and I thought that is very wrong because  that is obviously why I told the story  in part yeah like I know this about  myself anyway it looks like the the PGN  parse error which comes before the  resignation yeah there there they are on  your screen  uh ending the game  yeah uh a difficult decision the defeat  for ding who you know played about as  safely in the opening as you can imagine  in a joke